will you tell me about the proposal that
you did which is I just again where does
it end well this was I mean I wish I
could say that I'm usually this romantic
but this was a I was this was one of my
best okay I was I'm really proud of this
one so one morning I was sitting there I
was like okay tonight's tonight I think
I got to do it tonight I got to do it
tonight and and I thought okay we're
gonna do there's a beautiful little
Sandbar at Little Palm Island is where
we stayed and I had this idea to do this
like what if I put like a message in a
bottle that rolled up
and I went up to the concierge asked if
they had a old wine bottle they did took
some stationery from the hotel burned
the edges I had it all timed out with
the concierge so that
we're gonna be out at 5 15 for dinner I
need you to go put it like 5 14. have
the bottle in there so we can walk out
it's just rolling up to the thing and
that's when she found the bottle and
that's when I asked her to marry me and
it worked